♪ NOTE.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY.
TONIGHT BUCKLE UP.
WE HAVE BIG BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT MULTIPLE FRONTS.
UKRAINIAN IMPEACHMENT
FANTASY AS WE PREDICTED IT'S
NOW BLOWING UP IN HEIR FACES
JUST LIKE THE TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION BLEW UP IN THEIR
FACES.
IN MOMENTS WE WILL REVEAL
BRAND NEW EVIDENCE THAT WILL
ABSOLUTELY DESTROY THE
DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA'S
INSANE IMPEACHMENT
COMPULSIVE NARRATIVE.
INCLUDING BRAND NEW TEXT
MESSAGES PROVING PRESIDENT
TRUMP DID ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
WRONG DURING COMMUNICATIONS
WITH UKRAINE.
NON-WHISTLEBLOWER,
WHISTLEBLOWER TRUMP HATING
HACK AND DETAILS SURROUNDING
THE DEMOCRATS' FIRST START
WITNESS WHO POURED A TON OF
COLD WATER OVER EVERY
IMPEACHMENT FANTASY THEY
HAD.
YOU WILL NOTICE A COMMON
THEME IN THIS SHOW, THE
CORRUPTION, THE HYPOCRISY,
THE DECEIT OF BOTH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEIR
ALLIES, FRANKLY THEIR
STENOGRAPHERS THE MEDIA MOB.
EVERY ACCUSATION THEY MAKE,
EVERY ATTACK, EVERY SMEAR,
EVERY SLANDER EVERY ONE OF
THEM IS NOTHING MORE THAN
MERE PROJECTION.
THERIOT THE ONES GUILTY OF
REAL COLLUSION AND
CORRUPTION WITH UKRAINE JUST
LIKE THE BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN DOSSIER FULL OF LIES
IN 2016.
THEY ARE THE ONES GUILTY OF
CONSPIRACY.
THEY ARE THE ONES OUT THERE.
YEAH, JOE BIDEN LEVERAGING
YOUR TAX DOLLARS IN AN
OBVIOUS QUID PRO QUO IN A
SHAKEDOWN TO FIRE A
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR.
WHY WOULD A VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES EVER
WANT TO DO THAT?
AND THE ONES THAT COLLUDED
IN THE ELECTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
COMMITTED ZERO CRIME.
ZERO IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES
AND THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
MOB'S BASELESS CLAIMS ARE
UNRAVELING THIS HOUR
BREAKING TONIGHT STAR
WITNESS SHAM.
THE MEDIA MOB HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTELY GIDDY AGAIN JUST
LIKE RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA OVER THE
TESTIMONY OF FORMER AMERICAN
SPECIAL ENVOY TO UKRAINE
KURT VOLCKER.
THE A.P. REPORTED HE ADVISED
UKRAINIAN LEADERS ON HOW TO
NAVIGATE TRUMP'S DEMANDS FOR
A BIDEN PROBE FAKE NEWS
MSNBC AND VOLCKER WAS VALUE
BLING TO CONTAIN THE DAMAGE
NATIONAL SECURITY INFLICTED
BY RUDY GIULIANI.
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
VOLCKER TAINTED BY TRUMP'S
CORRUPTION AND THROWN UNDER
THE BUS BY TRUMP TEAM.
FAKE NEWS CNN WHY WOULD THEY
MISS OUT HYPING HIS
TESTIMONY AND WRITING,
QUOTE.
COLVER
VOLVER
VOLCER
VOLCKER HAS BECOME A KEY
PLAYER SURROUND THE
WHISTLEBLOWER COMPLAINT.
THE MOB SHEAR, YOU HADDER YOU
THE MOB SHEAR, YOU HADDER GOU
THE MOB SHEAR, YOU HADDER GIDDIE
THE MOB SHEAR, YOU HADDER GIDDIS
THE MOB SHEAR, YOU HADDER GIDDI.
IT ISN'T REPORTING.
WE SAW IT ALL UNFOLD ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE STATE DEPARTMENT'S
SPECIAL ENVOY TO UKRAINE
AMBASSADOR KURT VOLCKER NOT
ONLY QUITTING IN THE WAKE OF
THE BOMBSHELL WHISTLEBLOWER
COMPLAINT BUT NOW BEING
CALLED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
IN FRONT OF NOT ONE, NOT
TWO, BUT THREE CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES.
A BIG QUESTION TONIGHT WILL
THE WHITE HOUSE TAKE DRASTIC
MEASURES TO CONTROL WHAT HE
SAYS?
>> IF THE PRESIDENT THE
UNITED STATES USING OUR
FOREIGN POLICY TO LEVERAGE A
FOREIGN COUNTRY TO TAKE OUT
A RIVAL.
THAT'S A VERY SIMPLE STORY
THAT EVEN THE FOX AUDIENCE
CAN UNDERSTAND.
>> Sean: OH, SMELLY WALMART
SHOPPERS.
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES.
AS IT TURNS OUT YET AGAIN.
THERE IS JUST NO THERE
THERE.
THE ENTIRE LIE IS, AGAIN,
BLOWING UP IN THEIR FACES.
THE MOB IS ONCE AGAIN
BREATHLESSLY LYING AND
HYPING A HOAX.
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
ACCORDING TO OUR OWN
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, VOLCKER
TESTIFIED BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS YESTERDAY THAT THE
GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE WAS
NOT PRESSURED BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
HE ALSO NOTED THAT UKRAINE
NEVER RAISED ANY ISSUE OF
ANY QUID PRO QUO.
DID NOT VIEW THE PRESIDENT'S
CALL OR SUBSEQUENT
INTERACTIONS AT ALL IN ANY
WAY TO BE INAPPROPRIATE.
VOLCKER ALSO CONFIRMED
UKRAINE WAS NOT EVEN AWARE
THAT THE U.S. HOLD ON
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE WAS
THERE UNTIL LONG AFTER IT
WAS MADE PUBLIC, LONG AFTER
THE PRESIDENT'S CALL WITH
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
ZELENSKY.
AND ACCORDING TO A PARTIAL
TRANSCRIPT OF VOLCKER'S
TESTIMONY JUST RELEASED
EARLIER, QUOTE:  THE ISSUE
OF A HOLD PLACED ON SECURITY
ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE ALSO
CAME UP DURING THE SAME
TIME.
I WAS, WELL, CONNECTING
MR. URMAK AND MR. GIULIANI.
DID I NOT PERCEIVE THESE
ISSUES UTILIZED BY A
PRESIDENT WHO LOVES TO
NEGOTIATE AND IN THIS CASE
MORE FUNDING FROM OTHER
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES LIKE THEY
TALKED ABOUT IN THE
TRANSCRIPT IF YOU READ IT.
AND BY THE WAY, MOST
IMPACTED BY UKRAINE'S
CONFLICT WITH RUSSIA.
BOTH UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT AND
OUR PRESIDENT SAID YEAH,
EUROPEAN UNION IS NOT DOING
ENOUGH.
NOPE, GERMANY IS NOT DOING
FRANCE IS NOT DOING ENOUGH.
BY THE WAY, ONE MORE THING,
VOLCKER ALSO REPORTEDLY
TESTIFIED PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CONCERNS WERE VERY VALID AND
REAL LIKE WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU.
MEANWHILE DEMOCRATS'
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY IS
ANYTHING BUT VALID OR REAL.
WE HAVE NEWLY OBTAINED TEXT
MESSAGES FROM THE U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO THE EU GORDON
SONDLAND, AND CASTING EVEN
MORE DOUBT ON THE LEFT'S
UKRAINE HOAX IN A GROUP
MESSAGE WITH OTHER DIPLOMATS
THIS IS FROM SEPTEMBER,
WELL, SONDLAND SHOOTS DOWN
ANY SPECULATION ABOUT A
POLITICAL QUID PRO QUO.
HE WROTE, QUOTE:  I BELIEVE
YOU ARE INCORRECT ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
INTENTIONS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
CRYSTAL CLEAR NO QUID PRO
QUOS OF ANY KIND.
HE CONTINUES:  THE PRESIDENT
IS TRYING TO EVALUATE
WHETHER UKRAINE IS TRULY
GOING TO ADOPT THE
TRANSPARENCY AND THE REFORMS
THAT PRESIDENT ZELENSKY
PROMISED DURING HIS
CAMPAIGN.
THAT WAS ON THE CALL, TOO.
YOU READ THE TRANSCRIPT
LET'S GET THIS STRAIGHT.
THE SPECIAL ENVOY DIDN'T
BELIEVE HE DID ANYTHING
WRONG.
THE AMBASSADOR TO THE EU
DOESN'T THINK THE PRESIDENT
DID ANYTHING WRONG.
IF YOU READ IT, THERE IS
NOTHING WRONG THERE.
BUT KNOWN LIAR AND LEAKER
YES, THE COWARDLY SHIFTY
ADAM SCHIFF BELIEVES THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
TODAY EVEN "THE WASHINGTON
POST" HAD TO GIVE HIM FOUR
PINOCCHIOS ABOUT HIS LYING
ABOUT HIS COMMUNICATION WITH
THE NON-WHISTLEBLOWER
WHISTLEBLOWER WHO WE NOW
KNOW IS A DEMOCRAT WITH
DEMOCRATIC LEFT WING
ACTIVIST LAWYERS BRAGGING
ABOUT HELPING HIS TEAM.
NOW, REMEMBER SCHIFF SAID WE
HAVE NOT SPOKEN HIS OFFICE
HAD CONTACT WITH THE
WHISTLEBLOWER BEFORE THE
COMPLAINT WAS FIRED.
THEY ADVISED YOU BETTER GET
A LAWYER AND FILE A
COMPLAINT WITH THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND ORGANIZE.
THAT'S CALLED AN ORGANIZED
POLITICAL HIT FROM THE
GET-GO, AGAIN AND THEY ARE
CAUGHT AGAIN WE ARE LEARNING
A FAKE WHISTLEBLOWER,
NON-WHISTLEBLOWER
WHISTLEBLOWER IS A
REGISTERED DEMOCRAT.
PAUL OFFICERY, REAL CLEAR
INVESTIGATIONS REPORTING HE
WORKED IN THE OBAMA WHITE
HOUSE.
OH.
THAT EXPLAINS A LOT.
NO POLITICAL BIAS, RIGHT?
BUT THE LYING, COWARDLY
SHIFTY SCHIFF IS -- WANTS
YOU TO BELIEVE THIS IS JUST
NONPARTISAN EFFORT TO
PROTECT THE COUNTRY.
SHIFTY SCHIFF IS SO
CONCERNED ABOUT FOREIGN
ELECTION INTERFERENCE ALL OF
THE SUDDEN.
EXCEPT, I GUESS, WHEN IT'S
SHIFTY SCHIFF WHO IS TRYING
TO ELICIT THE FOREIGN
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE THAT TAPE.
THIS IS PRETTY ENTERTAINING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK THERE IS DIRECT
EVIDENCE IN THE EMAILS FROM
RUSSIANS INTERMEDIARY
OFFERING DIRT ON HILLARY
CLINTON THAT WHAT IS
DESCRIBED AS RUSSIAN EFFORT
TO ELECT DONALD TRUMP.
>> AND TRUMP AND WE RUSSIAN
GIRL CELEBRITY; ALSO KNOWN
AS PERSON WITH A STRANGE
REPUTATION.
>> OLGA AND HOW DO YOU SPELL
HER NAME.
>> OLGA BUZVA.
>> ENCOURAGED DON JR. TO DO
PRIVATELY.
THAT IS GIVE US THE DIRT ON
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> WHAT'S THE NATURE OF THE
KOMPROMAT?
>> WELL, THERE WERE PICTURES
OF NAKED TRUMP.
>> AND SO PUTIN WAS MADE
AWARE OF THE AVAILABILITY OF
THE COMPROMISING MATERIAL?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
>> WHAT MORE CLEAR INTENT TO
COLLUDE COULD YOU HAVE THAN
THE RUSSIANS OFFERING DIRT
ON HILLARY CLINTON AS PART
OF WHAT WAS DESCRIBED AS AN
EFFORT TO HELP MR. TRUMP IN
THE CAMPAIGN?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL BE BACK IN TOUCH
WITH YOU THROUGH OUR STAFF
TO MAKE ARRANGEMENTS TO
OBTAIN THESE FEERLS
MATERIALS FOR OUR COMMITTEE
AND THE FBI.
I APPRECIATE YOUR REACHING
OUT TO US.
>> Sean: WE HAVE
COMPROMISING MATERIALS.
WHAT'S THE NATURE OF THE
COMPROMISE.
NAKED PICTURES OF DONALD
TRUMP.
NAKED PICTURES.
HAS VLADIMIR SEEN IT?
DID HE SEE IT?
YEAH BUT OF COURSE WLADIMIR
SEEN NAKED PICTURES.
SCHIFF NOW A MAJOR SOURCE OF
EMBARRASSMENT FOR DEMOCRATS
IS HE ON TAPE DOING WHAT HE
SAID YOU SHOULDN'T DO.
ACCORDING TO GIULIANI THEY
MAY TRY TO REMOVE HIM AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE INAT INTEL
COMMITTEE.
IT'S CLEAR WHERE IT'S
SERIOUS.
CORRUPTION, LIES, DECEPTION,
DECEIT, HYPOCRISY, AGAIN
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND A
HOAX AGAIN.
IT'S SO BAD EVEN THE MEDIA
MOB ARE BEGINNING TO WORRY.
INCLUDING FAKE JAKE OVER
THERE AT FAKE NEWS AND EVEN
CNN'S VAN JONES WHO USED TO
WORK WITH OBAMA, THE GREEN
JOB CZAR WHATEVER JOB HE H
TAKE A LOOK.
DEMOCRATS ARE A LOSE LOSE
SITUATION.
IF THEY DON'T DO SOMETHING.
TRUMP GETS AWAY TOO MUCH.
IF YOU GO THROUGH WITH THE
IMPEACHMENT THOUGH YOU CAN
DIVIDE THE COUNTRY FURTHER.
TAKE THE OXYGEN AWAY FROM
YOUR CANDIDATE AND STILL
DON'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM WITH
FOREIGN INTERFERENCE.
>> Sean: EVEN PROFESSIONAL
JUMP HATER JEFFREY TUBEN.
TODAY ONE OF MANY REALLY
DUMB, AND I MEAN DUMB
LAWYERS ON TV THESE DAYS
WHOEVER THAT IS DOESN'T EVEN
SEE ANY CRIMINALITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK
IT IS -- IT IS CRIMINALITY.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY I HAVE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT THAT
QUESTION THOUGH, IS IT
EXTORTION?
IS IT BRIBERY?
YOU KNOW, I THINK IT SAN
ISSUE OF ABUSE OF POWER.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS AN
ACTUAL CRIMINALITY.
>> Sean: OH, EVEN HE CAN'T
COME UP WITH CRIMINALITY OR
HIGH CRIMES OR MISDEMEANORS
BECAUSE THERE IS NO QUID PRO
QUO NOTHING WRONG WITH THE
PHONE CALL.
NO PRESSURE.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO REMOVE
A DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT
OVER WHAT, EXACTLY?
WHAT?
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE HIM?
WE HAVE AN ELECTION IN A
YEAR.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU CAN PUT
UP.
I'M SURE YOU ARE TAKING THE
ADMONITION OF AL GREEN TO
HEART WHICH IS WE BETTER
IMPEACH HIM BECAUSE WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BEAT HIM.
REPUBLICANS ARE DARING
PELOSI AND THE PRESIDENT
DARING PELOSI TO HOLD AN
ACTUAL REAL VOTE.
I SECOND AND THIRD THE
MOTION.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, THIS IS
TURNING OUT TO BE ANOTHER
SPECTACULAR POLITICAL FAIL
FOR DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
ALLIES AND STENOGRAPHERS IN
THE MEDIA, THE MOB.
AND WHAT'S MORE, IT'S